back in the day before you got started
you worked a lot of different jobs into
the business and sort of behind the
scenes what could we doing anything
glamorous or was it all pretty
no it wasn't glamorous at all I did I
worked as a PA one of my first Jobs was
I worked as a production assistant on
Montel Williams directorial debut come
on tell Williams was the director did a
movie exactly he drew I think it was his
debut and his finale but he but he like
I like lock down a upstate New York we
like went and got paid 75 bucks for like
14 hour 15 hour days I think it was
illegal and I like locked down like a
basement just to watch like the trucks
and it was like a rat infested area and
I just was like like Kellyanne Conway in
the White House yeah and your job was
just to guard this stuff yeah just to
watch it for like ten hours right and
you what you also work for a Robert De
Niro's production I did I was I worked
as an assistant at Tribeca productions
because I was always obsessed with De
Niro as a lot of people were and I would
get to hang out with him monster I mean
he's he's a little socially I mean we're
both little socially awkward I think so
we didn't really connect in that way the
only thing I that came out of it was I
do I do good De Niro face now you can do
a good dinner here De Niro face
[Laughter]
and I do like emotions for every like
give me an emotion fear anger any ghost
Oh net that's very good that's the only
impression yeah yeah well he's gonna
contact you now
[Laughter]
you